Customer relationships is kind of a fourth piece,
and customer relationship has a really interesting interaction with these other three pieces.
It basically says how do I get customers, how do I keep them,
and how do I grow them, and just like thinking about distribution channels,
these are very different for web mobile than they are for physical channels.
But visually, they kind of look like this double-sided funnel.
Let's just take a look at quickly a web example--in getting customers, you're going to be
o worrying about how do I acquire them that is how do I get them even to my website,
how do I activate them that is how do I make them do something, and then later on
we'll see after I got them how do I keep them around that is how do I not lose them
through attrition and churn and then what can I do once I have customers
to make them spend more money or use my product even more.
One of the things we'll be thinking about is how do I get, keep, and grow customers.
And just like every other step, you might have hypothesis on day one,
but you're only going to figure this out when you're out of the building.